how are you Kyle how you been hey how's
it going man could I get to be on here
don't pretty good well yeah absolutely
and I just want to know if you heard
that introduction I would have had you
on even if we didn't have Chris on last
Friday you understand that I understand
he's smarter better-looking I did it
would you agree with that really you
know just do you really believe that
okay self-deprecation is kind of my
thing
yeah and plus you know unlike Urlacher
you're you're one of us who is uh
follically challenged Kyle right yeah
yeah you know I mean I didn't get the
cash in like liked it but uh you know I
think God wanted us to shine so finally
we'll do I like it Kyle I like that
attitude do you feel that the bandwagon
is full of folks jumping on the Bears
bandwagon Kyle cuz I certainly see it I
feel it you know you can always use more
and more fans but I think the ones we've
got are pretty awesome
they've been steadfast in their belief
in the Bears for at least the time that
I've been here I've been able to see
firsthand well then let then let me walk
you through one by one the the bandwagon
story lines that I'm hearing right now
that true Biscay looks so much more
ready to go and he looked ready to go
coming out of the box last year that
he's going to have a tremendous season
Kyle your thoughts on that I think mitch
has a tremendous support cast around
them in addition to his obvious talent
but I think the thing that separates him
is his ability to interact with his
teammates and rally the guys around an
idea and a belief and kind of an mo for
this team and you know we've been
obsessed with getting better since we
first got here the spring and Mitch has
been the leader well give me an example
of that how is he how is he led in the
manner in which you just described man
if we're in the huddle with the great
shuttle before he finishes the play call
he's the first one to call him out he's
also the first one to hold himself
accountable and ask us to hold him
accountable he's still still a rookie
until Game four so we still get to mess
with him in that regard
but you see his tremendous work ethic
and obviously the football end of it
takes care of itself I mean he's a good
football player he'll be able to excel
but just the way that he is in the
weight room the way is the footings the
way he conducts himself
you know in our free time I think really
sets the example and sets the bar high
for the rest of the team so how does he
ask to be held accountable or how has he
held himself accountable to you Kyle I
mean the little thing you know whether
with you know is if he doesn't feel his
attitude is up to par or he doesn't feel
his body language or his tempo you know
we we we like to run from drill to drill
and you know he'll even keep himself
intact like if we you know for fat guys
can run past him he's not he's not
running hard enough and you know little
things like that or what lets us know he
is a competitor sir-sir and a guy like
Brian Urlacher who you guys spoke with
he's another guy that wouldn't allow
himself to get beat on the way to a
drill even something as small as that
you know if you're a competitor you want
to compete all time car along here on
the Rich Eisen show and the other
storyline that we hear is - one of the
reasons why the Bears are going to excel
this year is based on you know it's a
copycat league and you got a second-year
quarterback taking high atop the draft
getting hooked up with an offensive guru
who's coming in in this first year in
the NFL and that happened with Sean
McVeigh and Jared Goff last year and
that's gonna have with Matt Negi and
Mitchell true Biscay how has Matt neji's
offense already looked to you Kyle I
just think the way he goes about his
business and you know he didn't want to
overload us too much and we've just been
trying to get the the basics of football
and you know we want to make sure that
our huddle is perfect we want to make
sure we're getting to the ball perfectly
guys are lining up in the right spots
and you know football is a game of
inches but it's also a game of very very
basic things especially it starts up
front with the offensive line and we
have a new addition area he stay on the
offensive line coach it was previously
here in Chicago they did a great job and
this time here he was another day in the
last few years and he's been great for
our room you know we have the largest in
terms of numbers number of players on
the field we have the largest position
group on the offense and it starts with
us and we know that the other guys will
follow suit and so how much different
will the offense look from last year
I'd say we got a lot of new personnel
that's something that you guys will see
and it'll be exciting to see some of
these playmakers going out there and
doing what they're supposed to do
give me one Allen Robinson for instance
I mean how's he look yeah Lenore Alan
Roberts is a man you know I've been
around some big physical freakish wide
receivers in my career and Roberts is
right up there with them what about
scheme wise scheme wise looking
different hmm you just come on why I
mean just dazed at telling tales out of
school I mean soon we'll be able to
secure 'ti public operational security I
like it all right so let's get down to
the most important stuff are you
watching the the Cutler cavalieri
reality show in that locker yeah you
know our left tackle Charles letteth got
us all TVs for the dorm room and you
know I guess whoever set it up didn't
really set it up the right way because I
don't have I don't have any channels but
I know I keep them up with I keep up
with the Cavallari keeping up with the
cavallaro's or the colors whatever it is
via text message because I can make fun
of Jay very Cavallari it's very Kristin
don't hit me
yeah they do a great job she's she's a
powerhouse man she's a stud and I think
you know Jays character traits are
perfect for reality because he is if he
hasn't also got out on TV as you guys
see what you see is what you get that is
the real alert we're getting the real
Cutler there yeah I've only seen clips
of it but what you see is what you get
with jacket which is see fit dry he's
funny and you know he pulls no punches
or doesn't he doesn't care that's what
it looks like he just doesn't care
[Laughter]
that's what I'm saying you just add to
that that plays very well on this show
is just like to see the raid I'm
interested to see the Reno you guys
probably talk ratings all see the
ratings when when Jays on there oh you
mean like spike it does its
bike it's what you're saying just I mean
it's gotta be a spike you know I don't
know I just think his wife probably gets
more of a rating spike I don't know how
many folks are out there but it's on
easy yeah I fast forward through all the
other stuff until Jays on is that right
yeah he's the best part I don't how many
people who watch you're like oh that's
that's the guy from from the Bears from
the Broncos I don't know how many people
know that how would you be on a reality
show Carl do you want one man I would
probably non-existent I would uh I'd be
I don't know I feel like if I made a
cameo on that show you get an idea a
little I want to see the murder of it
but yeah probably not
you know we live in a reality show here
it you know live at there's training
camp you know I dunno what you're saying
it's the it's the greatest reality show
on television is the National Giada
League sir you've known that for a long
time
hey this this new helmet rule everyone
talks about the defense this is going to
apply to folks like you if you lead with
your helmet and some sea air pulling
you're doing some sort of action and are
you concerned about this new rule being
applied to offensive linemen well you
know I'm glad you asked because ever I
think it's a defensive thing but uh you
know from a young age my dad always
taught me see what you get at that
regard it means keeping your face mask
as the point of contact or your hands
you know hands and feet are what win
football games if you put your head down
you don't see what you hear you can get
swam you can get you know swiped out of
the way but I think it's really it's a
it's a really good progression to a
safer tomorrow for the youth coming up
that re playing football it's a smart
way to teach kids you know see what you
hit don't put your head down and put you
it put yourself at risk as much as it
puts but the recipient of the contact at
risk are you concerned though that the
officials are not on the same page for
this yet that that there's an intent and
a spirit that is as you just pointed out
coming from a good place but in terms of
the actual adjudication of this with the
the the games right around the corner we
saw what happened in the game that you
were in just last Thursday are you
concerned about that
my only concern is that the UH you know
make this game so long
games are gonna get so long because
everything will be it will get looked at
will get refuted and I don't know if
it's one of those things where they look
at it and they have to make a decision
on it or if the call of the call but I
definitely noticed that there were there
a lot of breaks in the action but it's
preseason and the points of emphasis
from the officiating staff and the
officiating crew all over the league is
something that every 32 NFL teams have
that video we watch the video a drink in
know everybody knows what the rule
changes are and what they're going to be
looking at and looking at changing and
you know we knew the flags will fly for
that kind of stuff so they just want to
you know hammer at home and get it
through our heads that no pun intended
yeah I know she call I mean we got to
choose different words right the hammer
at home get it through your heads right
I mean yeah yeah it's a point of
emphasis so yes I have no argument
against that and give me your best
Urlacher memory as you just pointed out
right there in is Brian going in oh just
this probably all the stories I've heard
about Brian as a teammate you know his
his spirit it's something that a lot of
the staff that has been here since I've
been here we're here when Brian was Oh
Sam came in you came in just after him
right he just right right when I showed
up in 13 Brian had had left and so that
was really my only my only gripe I never
got to play Oh 54 and he is a legend
around here and the great thing is he's
present in our in our facility and he's
somebody that's around and it's
important for young guys aim and all
guys to see him around and get to pick
his brain hey Kyle thanks for the time
man so you have no TV in in a training
camp is what you're saying no screens on
TV what the hell are you fine with that
are you good with that yeah I'm good
with that I have an iPad so I can look
at all our scheme okay your scheme and
you're not you're not revealing
whatsoever at all yes football just
football since Kyle long okay I'll take
that I'll do my best with it and at
least you got your iPad you could keep
up with with Cutler I'm very Cavallari
or keeping up camera learn whatever the
hell jack on it
alright calm you take care of yourself
brother let's go you bet that's Kyle
long the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience